volunteers are working to help raise
funds to rescue golden retrievers out of
china and the next step is to get all
those dogs to loving homes right here in
southern nevada we caught up with the
committee chair of goldens without
borders who lives in henderson about the
challenges this particular rescue group
is dealing with during this pandemic
it just means a lot to me to say that
margot rogat is a dog lover is an
understatement
this is one of the happiest moments for
her greeting these pups at lax it means
she saved a golden retriever headed to
the slaughterhouse in china or from a
life spent in a cage
margo's basically the head honcho
volunteer at goldens without borders
it's an international rescue that has in
the past relied on passenger flights to
transport these dogs from china to lax
and then drive them safely home to las
vegas but due to coveted restrictions
it's much more complicated and expensive
now we have an unbelievable rescue
partner in china and we arranged for all
the flights and everything to come into
the states have changed dramatically
since cobit and i do need dramatically
because now the dogs can only be
transported as cargo and the cost to do
so has more than quadrupled as a result
volunteers fundraise to cover the cost
and prepare all the necessary paperwork
for travel permits to the u.s oversea
rescue partners provide a safe
environment and prepare the dogs for
travel which includes vaccinations and
quarantine there's just a lot of dogs
that still need to come over here she
says it's rewarding work when you see
these dogs experience their first taste
of freedom
from where they've come and from the
life that they've known
which is not a life
and for many of them
it doesn't really become a life because
we can't save them all
but for the ones that we do
their lives are changed forever these
dogs are living
such a long life i mean
just
going to the beach or going to the snow
or kayaking or boating or lounging in a
swimming pool
there you go
and once they get here to las vegas
they're placed in foster families and
then they get the process to actually
adopt so it takes a little bit but
there's so many ways to get involved you
know that's such a great cause and
golden retrievers who doesn't want a
golden retriever they know they're such
lovely lovely dogs and of course there
are so many rescue organizations across
the country for so many different breeds
this happens to be for those now there
is a big fundraiser coming up in one
week it's called life is golden it's
taking place next thursday august 19th
at 5 30 at dragon ridge country club at
mcdonald highlands if you can't make the
event though and you just want to donate
to the cause you can do so at goldens
without borders dot org